[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So today we're going to
continue our discussion
about photosynthesis.
And last time, I introduced
the reactions of photosynthesis
and pointed out that really
what we're talking about
is oxidation
reduction reactions.
And so the net reaction
of photosynthesis--
water plus carbon dioxide goes
to carbohydrate and oxygen--
is really the opposite
of burning wood.
So if burning wood, carbon
oxidation, is favorable,
reversing this, obviously,
needs energy input.
And that energy input is light
that's coming from the sun.
And we started to discuss a bit
about how this reaction works.
And I mentioned
that photosynthesis
is broken down into light
reactions and dark reactions.
And so the light
reactions are really
along the same lines of the
oxidative phosphorylation
electron transport
chain that we described.
And that is basically
using energy
from the sun to use water
as an electron donor
to generate NADPH,
as well as oxygen.
In doing so, light from the sun
makes this process favorable.
That favorable electron
transport can then
be used to generate delta psi,
delta pH, which can create ATP,
do other work just like
oxidative phosphorylation.
Of course, photosynthesis
comes first, oxidative
phosphorylation came second,
even though we taught it
in the reverse order.
And these reactions
also produce NADPH,
which can be used in the
so-called dark reactions
to synthesize carbohydrates.
Now, the dark reactions,
again, I mentioned,
can be done in the
light or the dark.
They don't need light.
They use the NADPH from
the light reactions,
as well as the ATP produced
from the light reactions
to take CO2 and turn
it into carbohydrate.
And that allows plants to store
carbon, reduced carbon energy,
for later, such that
when the sun is not
shining they can then use that
carbohydrate to oxidize it
in all of the reactions
we've already learned about
and make sure they're
able to generate ATP,
keep their ATP-ADP
ratio high at night,
and then switch back to
using photosynthesis when
the sun is out during the day.
Now, today what we're
going to discuss
is both the light and the
dark reactions in great detail
to fill in how those
processes happen.
So first, we're going to start
with the light reactions.
And so the light
reactions, if it's
like oxidative
phosphorylation, that
is we're going to generate
a membrane potential,
build a battery, that is
to occur at a membrane.
And so those membranes are the
cell membrane of a bacteria,
or prokaryote, or an
intracellular membrane
of a eukaryotic
photosynthetic organism.
And that intracellular membrane
is, of course, the chloroplast
that you learned
about in grade school.
And so the chloroplast is
the photosynthetic equivalent
of the mitochondria.
Oxidative phosphorylation
in eukaryotes
happen at a
mitochondrial membrane.
And photosynthesis
in eukaryotes happens
at a chloroplast membrane.
And so, just to be
explicit about this,
so if this is our
photosynthetic bacteria,
some prokaryotic cell, it
will use photosynthesis
to make delta psi, delta pH
across the cell membrane.
And then it can utilize
that to provide energy
for the organism,
very similar to what
we said about oxidative
phosphorylation in a bacteria.
And you can imagine
that then there
was some early eukaryotic
cell that ended up engulfing
this photosynthetic prokaryote.
And in the process,
the ATP generated
could be exchanged for ADP
across those membranes.
And in the end, this is
how one ends up with this
double-membraned organelle
within the engulfed prokaryotic
species, with having the
membrane potential built across
this--
oops-- having the
membrane potential
built across this inner
mitochondrial membrane--
or inner membrane of, in
this case, the chloroplast.
And so, if you remember,
we drew the mitochondria
as having this double
membrane structure,
the inner
mitochondrial membrane,
where oxidative
phosphorylation happen.
Protons were pumped into
this intermembrane space.
And chloroplasts have
basically the same structure,
but it's a little
bit more complicated,
at least on the surface.
And that's because chloroplasts
have evolved this further
to have what, essentially,
are extreme cristae,
those folds of the
mitochondria called cristae.
These extreme folds is basically
what happens in a chloroplast.
So if we draw here a
giant chloroplast--
so this here would be the outer
membrane of the chloroplast.
So the chloroplast also
has an inner membrane.
So this here is then the inner
membrane of the chloroplast.
You can imagine that if you
had this extreme folding
in of the cristae, but
actually pinched off
this little piece of
membrane here, you
would now end up with
stacks of membrane
within the chloroplast.
You still here have
this inner membrane here
that goes all the
way around, but now
you have these little
membrane stacks that now
exist within the chloroplast.
These here is called grana.
And this inside of these stacks,
what is called the lumen,
is really the equivalent
of the intermembrane space
of the mitochondria.
So the inside of this
is basically equivalent
to the intermembrane
space of the mitochondria,
such that if I draw one of these
pinched off pieces of membrane
in gigantic form, you're
basically pumping protons
into the lumen, into this
intermembrane space equivalent.
And so you can imagine that you
have this electron transport
chain set up, where electrons
are transferred from water
to NADP+, making
oxygen an NADPH.
That is, electron
transport is made favorable
by light that generates
a membrane potential
across this membrane, which
is, by the way, this membrane--
which is the same
there-- this is
called the thylakoid membrane.
Thylakoid--
T-H-Y-L-A-K-O-I-D-- membrane.
So you build a potential
across this thylakoid membrane,
and then that
potential can be used
to synthesize ATP
within this other space,
this wider space here, which
is called the stroma, which
is the equivalent of the
matrix of the mitochondria.
And so basically,
the chloroplast
is set up in a very similar
way to the mitochondria,
but because it makes
these membrane stacks,
it looks like it's a
little bit different.
But it's really pumping protons
into the intermembrane space,
which would happen in the
mitochondria an equivalent
space, which is the
lumen of these stacks,
is what happens within
the chloroplast.
That charge on the membrane,
that delta psi, delta pH,
can then be used to do
work like synthesizing ATP.
That happens in-- rather than--
and that happens in the stroma
of the matrix equivalent,
the stroma of the chloroplast.
And so effectively,
you have NADPH,
an ATP produced in the stroma.
And so it turns out the
dark reactions, when
we talk about them
later, will occur here
in the stroma of
the chloroplast.
And the light
reactions, of course,
are happening over here
at the thylakoid membrane.
Now, this is actually
a cool innovation
that nature has come
up with for this.
And because by making
these extreme cristae,
you can imagine that
there's a very small space
here that you're
pumping protons into.
That means that fewer protons
pump will allow you to generate
a higher potential, a higher
gradient of protons, delta pH.
And so that means that that
then can be used to drive energy
in a more efficient
way then you might
get using this much larger
intermembrane space.
And so light reactions here
at the thylakoid membrane
within the chloroplast,
dark reactions
here in the stroma
of the chloroplast.
All right.
So that's the anatomy.
Now, let's get back to what's
actually happening here
in these light reactions.
So of course, the trick
of the light reactions
is to come up with some way
to make water a good electron
donor, such that you can
have favorable electron
transfer to NADPH, which
is, of course, what's
necessary to have energy
released to generate delta psi,
delta pH.
And so, of course,
to do this, we still
have to follow all the same
thermodynamic rules that
existed before,
that we talked about
for oxidative phosphorylation.
So you should remember
from those lectures
that electron transfer
is going to be favorable
if we move from a lower
to a higher standard
reduction potential.
So if we just draw this out.
So here's a physiological
range of standard reduction
potentials from negative
1.6 to positive 0.8 volts.
So this here would be a range of
standard reduction potentials.
So remember, a change in
standard reduction potential
that's positive, that means
moving this direction down,
as I've drawn this axis
from smaller to larger.
I realize I drew it upside
down in the way you probably
are normally used
to looking at this.
But basically, if
you go from a more
negative to a positive
number, or a more negative
to a less negative, or a
positive to a more positive,
basically, a change
in this direction,
which is going to
have a positive change
in standard reduction
potential, is
going to end up having a
negative change in delta g--
not prime.
And so that means
equilibrium is going
to favor electron transport
moving down in this direction.
So now, let's just give
this some real numbers.
So the standard reduction
potential of oxygen water
sits down here.
It's 0.86.
You don't have to worry
about exact numbers.
The standard reduction
potential of NADH, or NADPH,
they're the same.
The nicotinamide group is here.
It's about negative 0.32.
And this is why oxidative
phosphorylation works
is because there is
a net positive change
in standard reduction potential.
That is, you go from a
lower to a higher standard
reduction potential
if we do electron
transport in the
oxidative phosphorylation.
That means energy is released
as we transfer electrons
from NADH to oxygen.
So that is favorable.
That favorable energy
release is what
can be coupled to proton
pumping to generate
delta psi, delta pH, and allow
the cell to do other work.
Now, you cannot change the
properties of water just
because you add light to it.
So it still sits at this
standard reduction potential.
But what happens
in photosynthesis
is basically you use light
to excite an electron.
That effectively
moves water up here
to a more negative
electron up here,
to generate an
electron that's up here
at a more negative
standard reduction
potential than NADPH, which,
of course, now moving down,
becomes favorable.
And so here, now you're going
from more negative to here.
And then from there to there,
each of those is favorable.
This means you can use
this favorable electron
transfer, the energy release
from the favorable movement
of electrons from this
excited electron, to NADPH,
generate NADPH.
And then you can also use--
donate those to the
electron transport chain
and OXPHOS with oxygen--
with water-- with oxygen as the
final electron acceptor to net
generate delta psi,
delta pH in OXPHOS.
And so this works to generate
it in photosynthesis,
and this works to generate it
in oxidative phosphorylation.
And we've not violated any
laws of thermodynamics.
And we're able
to, in both cases,
create this membrane
potential, build
this battery, that
now allows you
to do work such
as synthesize ATP,
keep the ATP-ADP ratio
high, allow the cell
to do all the unfavorable
reactions that it needs to do.
So now, let's talk a
bit about this process.
So of course, this happens
with visible light,
but I want to start with
asking a fundamental question.
Why do we use visible light?
Or, to put it another way,
what is visible light, anyway?
Well, visible light
is, of course, just
electromagnetic
radiation, a photon
on the electromagnetic
radiation spectrum.
And visible light is
defined by what we see.
So if we draw this out--
this is hopefully
something that you've
covered in a physics class
somewhere along the way.
So if this here is the
electromagnetic magnetic
spectrum as drawn out-- so
down here you have your short
wavelength
electromagnetic radiation,
down here you have your
long wavelength things--
so higher energy, lower energy--
and on this end,
X-ray, UV light.
And you get to the
visible spectrum
and we go from the purple
light down to the red light.
And eventually, we get
into the infrared light,
and ultimately,
down to microwaves,
and basically shorter wavelength
and longer length wavelengths,
more energy, less energy.
And so just to give you
some numbers, so this here
is on the order
of 300 kilojoules,
of 170 kilojoules.
And so ADP to ATP
conversion-- so we before
talked about in kcals
per mole, but it's
on the order of 30
kilojoules for that.
And so this part of the
electromagnetic spectrum
is the right order
of magnitude, it
turns out, to transduce
energy in a realm that
matches the energy required,
or release, from the ATP
to ADP conversion reaction.
You also know from
just popular use,
you go out in the sun
when it's a nice day,
you put sunscreen on.
Why do you do that?
That's because the
UV light that's
filtered through our
atmosphere from the sun
can cause sunburns.
That is, it can cause
damage to our skin,
to other biological molecules.
Obviously, X-rays, you
go get an X-ray done,
you get covered with lead
in all the places they don't
want to have the X-ray done.
Why?
Because X-rays can cause damage.
We use those to treat cancer.
And so things down on this
end, too much energy damages
biological molecules.
This is the sweet spot where
you don't get a lot of damage
to the biological molecules.
And the energy is
right to synthesize--
to transduce energy
on a magnitude that
works for biological systems.
Come down to this
end, well, now you
get to be too little energy.
You get down to the
infrared and the microwaves.
This is like your
TV remote control.
This is the cell phones that
if you were in class as opposed
to listening to this online,
you would be checking
instead of listening to me.
So this direction,
too little energy
is transduced to actually matter
for the biological systems.
And so that's really why
this spectrum of light
is what's involved
in photosynthesis.
However, I also
want to remind you
that visible light
is a human construct.
It's what we as humans can see.
And photosynthesis evolved
long before humans.
We needed photosynthesis
first before any animal life
can evolve.
And so this visible
light designation
is completely arbitrary.
And in fact, we evolved from
photosynthetic organisms.
And so it's really
photosynthetic pigments
that evolved first to
capture light in this range
that we then repurposed
in order to see.
So in essence, photosynthesis
defines the visual spectrum,
because what we see is
defined by the pigments that
came-- because it evolved
from photosynthesis.
The carotenoids,
the carrot, the why
do eat carrots that
are good for our eyes?
They have the pigments
in carrots, carotenoids--
which we'll draw
in a little bit--
that are ultimately related
to our visual pigments.
And we didn't invent those.
Photosynthetic
organisms invented
those to work in this
spectrum to harvest light
from the sun for energy.
And we repurposed those
molecules as a way for us
to see.
So how does this work?
Well, again, I got to remind you
of a little bit more physics,
a little quantum physics.
This is not--
obviously, we're not
going to go into
this at the level you
get in a physics
class, and hopefully
you've seen this before.
But you remember,
if you think back
to physics and
physical chemistry,
that electrons sit in discrete
orbitals within molecules.
So we can draw those
orbitals like this.
And so you'd have some
electron pair sitting there
in some orbital in a molecule.
And if you deliver light with
the right amount of energy,
the right quanta of
energy, you can now
excite one of those electrons
up here into a orbital
with a higher energy.
And of course, that's not
stable, so it will decay.
And when that electron decays
back to the ground state,
this then re-releases
another photon of light
at a longer wavelength.
So longer wavelength
light is emitted,
and that's effectively
fluorescence.
So you excite something,
electron bounces up
into a higher
orbital, it decays,
releases some of the
energy that it absorbed
as it transitions back.
That is fluorescence.
This happens very, very fast.
And basically what
photosynthesis
does is it takes advantage
of this excited state.
And it effectively transfers
that electron away,
creating a charged
separation prior
to that electron decaying back
into the ground state orbital.
This occurs very fast.
And so photosynthesis has to
occur very, very fast in order
to make this work.
And in essence, this is
the way that photosynthesis
is able to capture
energy and connect it
to a biological system
that allows us to build
an electron transport chain.
And so in essence,
photosynthesis, the way
the energy is absorbed, is it's
what you learned in physics.
The right quanta of
light causes an electron
to excite into a
higher energy orbital.
And then that electron
is transferred away,
creating a charged
separation before
that energy of that
excited electron
can decay as fluorescence.
That creates a
charged separation.
And that charged separation
now has an electron such
that that electron can now be
favorably transferred to NADPH.
That energy released in
that favorable transfer
can be coupled to make
delta psi, delta pH.
And then that
translates as energy
in exactly the same
way we learned about
for oxidative phosphorylation.
So to do this, what do we need?
Well, we need a pigment that
can absorb a photon of the right
wavelength-- or, put it another
way, of the right energy--
and then quickly transfer
that electron away.
And so you need two things.
You need light
acceptors that can
absorb energy of
the right energy,
the right wavelength of light,
and redox carriers to transfer
those electrons away.
So what are the light acceptors?
Well, these are
basically pigments
that can absorb visible light.
And redox carriers
are electron carriers,
which we've been talking about
now for several lectures.
So let's start with
the light acceptor.
So this is something that's
tuned to the right energy,
the right wavelength.
And so this is chlorophyll.
So we all know plants
contain chlorophyll.
That's important
for photosynthesis.
Well, what is chlorophyll?
Well, it's a conjugated
pyrrole, very similar
to heme, except remember,
heme had iron in it.
Saw that for hemoglobin, saw it
again in the electron transport
chain.
And I'm going to
show you chlorophyll.
Chlorophyll is going to
look a lot like that,
except it has a magnesium
conjugated to the tetrapyrrole
rather than iron.
And so here you
have tetrapyrrole
with a magnesium in the
middle, conjugated double bond
system all the way around.
Makes sense, that should
absorb visible light,
all those conjugated
double bonds.
There's some R group decorations
hanging off over here.
Chlorophyll also has this
additional decoration
over here, including a long
lipid tail here to make this--
it will sit within a membrane.
Oops.
Apologies.
I misdrew that.
Lipid tail hangs off down there.
But this here is
effectively what
the structure of
chlorophyll looks like,
with this R and R prime
being specific groups.
You can look up if
you're interested.
But basically, these
are the decorations
that define what I refer to as
A type and B type chlorophylls.
Remember, we had A, B, and
C type cytochromes that
were basically similar molecules
with slightly different
decorations on them, the
types defined slightly
by the absorbance properties
of these pigments.
But effectively, what's
key about chlorophyll
is that it's this
conjugated, double bond
system in the tetrapyrrole
that ultimately allows
it to absorb visible light.
Now, chlorophyll is, of course,
the most famous pigment,
but it's not the only pigment
that photosynthetic organisms
used.
So they also use other pigments
to absorb visible light.
And so there is a class
of pigments that look
very similar to chlorophyll.
You can look up the
structures if you want.
They're called phytobilins.
They're also tetrapyrroles,
very similar to chlorophyll,
except, for instance,
pheophytin does not
contain any magnesium or other
thing conjugated in the center,
so no magnesium.
Otherwise, it looks
similar to chlorophyll.
And then there's other ones.
There's so-called phycoerythrin,
which you might guess is red.
So that's a red pigment.
There's phycocyanin,
which is, you might guess,
is a blue pigment.
And then maybe the most
famous one that about that's
not chlorophyll are the
so-called carotenoids.
This includes things
like beta-carotene.
I think we all know that
beta-carotene is orange.
What does beta-carotene
look like?
I'll draw it out for you.
There's beta-carotene, another
long conjugated, double bond
system.
Obviously, you don't
need to memorize
the structures of any of these.
You can always look up
structures of these pigments.
The point is that nature has
a variety of these structures,
all with conjugated
double bond systems,
all well-tuned to
absorb visible light.
And this, of course, also
then becomes a major pigment
for our visual
system, repurposed
from the plant using it
for chlorosynthesis--
for photosynthesis.
And why have all these pigments?
Well, the idea is
because if we say here,
what's the absorbance then
across the electromagnetic
spectrum, that the purple,
the short wavelength,
being down here, and the
red, the long wavelength,
being on this end,
well now, effectively,
you have chlorophylls
that cover that spectrum.
And so you'll have
some peak here
for say A type chlorophylls.
And then you'll have some other
peak for B type chlorophylls.
These are obviously approximate.
And so that's basically the
A and B type chlorophylls.
Why are plants green?
Because they absorb in two
peaks on either end, and so that
reflects the green
light in the middle.
But now you have
these other pigments
that will fill in the middle.
And so the beta-carotene,
the orange beta-carotene,
will allow you to--
plants, they'll have an
absorption spectrum that will
peak somewhere in that range.
And then you'll have
the phycoerythrins
with an absorption spectrum
that will peak somewhere
in that range.
And then the phycocyanins
with an absorption spectrum
that will peak
somewhere in that range.
And basically, by covering all
of these different pigments,
plants and other
photosynthetic organisms
can now adapt to
different light niches
within the natural world, really
capturing the full spectrum
of visible light.
And the nice thing
is this also leads
to all the beautiful
colors and whatnot
that exists across
photosynthetic organisms,
different plants, algaes, and
bacteria, all different colors.
And basically will use
these different pigments
to ultimately cover this visual
spectrum, this right spectrum
with the right amount
of energy to carry out
the processes that's necessary
to run the light reactions
of photosynthesis.
Now, even though there's
this variety of pigments,
effectively, all photosynthetic
organisms, as far as we know,
work in a very similar
way, in that they basically
arrange these pigments
always at a membrane,
always here at this thylakoid
membrane in the chloroplast--
or, I guess it would be the
cell membrane of a prokaryote.
And these are organized
into a structure called
the light harvesting complex.
And basically, what a
light harvesting complex
is, is it's pigments arranged
in a structure that basically
can channel energy from
the photons captured down
into a place called
the reaction center.
So you can imagine that you'd
have all kinds of pigments
arranged in a way that basically
will absorb photons, release
photons as fluorescence,
ultimately going down
to this reaction center.
And it's in the reaction
center that really the magic
of photosynthesis happens.
So what happens at
the reaction center
is pretty well understood
from the structure
of the photosynthetic
reaction center that
was solved about 30 years ago
in the purple photosynthetic
bacteria.
And this is very illustrative
for how it works.
And so if you look
here at the slide,
this here is basically a
graphical representation
of what that reaction
center looks like.
And so effectively,
you have a bunch
of, in this particular
case, molecules up here.
But really, the reaction center
is what exists down here.
And in there, there is
a pair of chlorophylls--
we'll talk about in a second.
Those are they're shown
graphically over here.
And they will effectively
transfer electrons
around in this direction to
these quinones further away
from the special
pair of chlorophyll.
So electrons will be
transferred from the chlorophyll
after it's excited
down to these quinones,
creating a charged separation
that ultimately is going
to allow you to then have
a high-energy electron that
can be built into an
electron transport chain.
And so let's draw that
graphically out over here.
And so here if we have our
special pair of chlorophylls--
so chlorophyll, if
you look at it here,
is relatively a pyrrole.
Like heme, it's a flat
molecule, and so these will
stack on top of each other.
So if they're stacked
on top of each other
and this is looking
at them head on,
you have this special
pair of chlorophylls.
You'll eventually-- you'll
absorb a photon of light,
and that will create
a charge separation
a cross between that special
pair of chlorophylls.
That electron, before it
can decay as fluorescence,
as would normally happen, it's
very rapidly transferred out
to a pheophytin molecule.
And then it's very
rapidly transferred again
to a quinone called QA.
All right, so just show
that again here on here.
So here's our special pair.
You absorb a photon of
light, charge separation
at the special pair, electron
transfer to the pheophytin,
and then down to this quinone.
And that's a very fast reaction.
And you can see
that it's actually
moving within space that's
roughly the distance from one
side of the membrane to another.
So on an atomic level,
quite a long distance.
And so from this
quinone, it then
will be transferred again
to a second quinone.
That's a slower step.
I want to remind
you how electrons
are transferred on quinones.
And so we talked
about this already
when we talked about
electron transport.
So here is a--
so this here would be
an oxidized quinone
just like we saw for
coenzyme Q, ubiquinone.
So this would be oxidized
quinone and photosynthesis.
Electron, you can pick up
electrons one at a time,
so that will generate
this semiquinone.
Remember, with the
stabilized free radical,
now you can pick up
a second electron.
And that ultimately generates
the reduced, the fully reduced
quinone, the quinol.
We talked about
this with coenzyme Q
and oxidative phosphorylation.
Remember, ubiquinone
to ubiquinol,
similar thing happening
in photosynthesis.
Also, a quinone can pick up
electrons, go from the oxidized
to the reduced state.
And if you remember, in
oxidative phosphorylation,
you could then, as you
transfer the electrons
across from the oxidized and
reduced state of the quinones,
you'll pick up a proton.
If you pick up those protons
and release those protons
as you transfer electrons
on different sides
of the membrane,
that can be coupled
to pump protons
across the membrane
as you transfer electrons
across the system, exactly what
happens here in photosynthesis.
Except now that
electron is basically
coming from transfer
of an excited
electron from the special
pair to the pheophytins,
and ultimately to the quinones.
And then from the quinones,
can now be transferred down
on electron transport chain.
To show this in a quantum
way, if you will--
so if this here is the
special pair of chlorophyll
and we draw here the
pair of electrons
in the special pair
in the ground state,
if you get a photon of
light of the right energy,
you excite one of
those electrons
here into a higher orbital.
Before that can decay, if we
transfer that electron out,
basically take that electron
and transfer it out,
and instead here give
it to the pheophytin--
so here's some orbital in
the pheophytin-- it comes,
it picks up this electron
that's transferred away
from the special pair.
Well, now, what you
have is you basically
have a negative charge
here and a positive charge
up on the special pair.
So you've created this
charge separation.
That electron can then be
further transferred down
the electron transport
chain to the quinones, that
then transfer them
across the quinones, who
are pumping proton.
And ultimately, down an
electron transport chain,
ultimately with the final
electron acceptor being
in NADP+ to make NADPH.
And you're still left
with this positive charge
on the special pair.
Obviously, that's not
a very stable state,
so we've got to resolve that.
How can that be resolved?
Well, lots of things will--
that's a pretty good electron
acceptor.
And so now, even
something like water,
which is highly abundant,
can be an electron donor,
and ultimately fixes
that positive charge
on the special pair by taking
electron from water, which,
of course, generates oxygen.
This part of the reaction is
carried out by a complex called
the water splitting complex-
We: don't have time to get
into this--
and some
manganese-containing enzyme.
And it basically
controls the transfer
of an electron from water
to oxygen, which, hopefully,
is at least intuitively you'll
see why that's favorable,
because you really have
this true positive charge
on the special pair.
And almost anything is
a good electron donor
to that, including water.
And so it's really this charge
separation by fast electron
transfer through
the reaction center
from the special
chlorophyll pair
ultimately down to quinones that
creates this charged separation
that is ultimately where you
can pull an electron from water
to generate oxygen. And
if we come back over here,
it's how we made this whole
process work, how we made water
on a good electron donor.
That is, we didn't make
the standard-- didn't
change the standard
reduction potential
of the oxygen-water pair.
Instead, what we
did is we basically
used light to excite an
electron in chlorophyll such
that that excited
electron now can
be favorably-- sits at a low
enough standard reduction
potential such that it's
favorable to transfer
it to NADPH.
And then we fix that
charge hole, if you will,
by pulling an
electron from water,
and that generates oxygen.
Of course, once we're able to
get this favorable electron
transfer, now we can couple
that to the pumping of protons.
That allows us to make
delta psi, delta pH.
We charge a battery,
and that does work,
just like we saw before.
So why these concepts were
so important to understanding
how energy transduction and
biological systems work,
and why I spent so
much time talking
about standard
reduction potentials,
delta psi, delta pH, et cetera.
Now, I want to
describe these concepts
and build them into the context
of a chloroplast electron
transport chain.
I'm going to show you what
happens in chloroplasts
in higher plants.
Conceptually, even though
the details may not
be 100% the same across all
photosynthetic organisms,
conceptually what
I'm going to show you
is exactly the
same, regardless of
whether it's a
photosynthetic bacteria
or a chloroplast from a plant.
So if we draw here--
this here being the
thylakoid membrane--
so I'm going to draw it such
that this here is the stroma
side of the membrane.
This is the lumen
Remember, the
stroma side would be
equivalent to the matrix of the
mitochondria, where the lumen
side would be equivalent
to the intermembrane space
of the mitochondria.
So thylakoid membrane,
stroma side, lumen side.
We have a complex here.
This complex is
called photosystem II,
abbreviate PSII.
Photosystem II is
going to be linked up
to the water splitting complex,
which will basically pick up
an electron, of course,
injecting light that
will transfer electrons
through effectively
what is a Q cycle, what
we alluded to happens
in oxidative phosphorylation--
I didn't have time to
describe it in great detail--
that can pump protons
across the membrane,
as electrons are transferred
into the next complex, which
is called cytochrome bf.
The next complex,
cytochrome bf, also
can pump protons
across the membrane.
Those electrons
then get transferred
to a soluble protein in the
lumen called plastocyanin.
From there, those
electrons now get
transferred to another complex
called photosystem I, or PSI.
Electrons in photosystem I
can end up in another complex
called ferredoxin, ultimately
transferring those electrons
to NADP+ to generate NADPH.
And of course, that
will happen here
on the stromal side
of the membrane,
because that's where
the dark reactions are
going to take place.
This has the effective
generating a delta psi,
delta pH across the membrane.
And of course, that
can be used then,
that delta psi, delta pH can
be used by a chloroplast F0,
chloroplast F1 to
generate ATP, just
like we described from
oxidative phosphorylation,
with the ATP also being
generated on the stromal side
of the membrane.
So this should look
very similar to what
we described for mitochondrial
electron transport.
So you see we have multiple
complexes, including
a cytochrome C-like protein
that sits on, in this case,
the lumen side of the thylakoid
membrane, plastocyanin.
Cytochrome C sits in
the intermembrane space
of the mitochondria.
You transfer electrons,
including via Q,
quinone-like, cycle
that pumps protons,
have other complexes
that pump protons,
ultimately transfer
electrons to generate NADPH.
There's two complexes here that
absorb light, photosystem II
and photosystem I. Electron
transfer, I guess, classically,
would go photosystem II,
cytochrome bf, plastocyanin,
photosystem I, ferredoxin.
Water is the donor,
NADPH as the acceptor,
generates delta psi, delta pH.
That delta psi,
delta pH can then
be used to do work, including
synthesis of ATP, as done
by an F0F1-ATPase, just like
exists in the mitochondria.
Of course, this evolved first.
And so oxidative phosphorylation
looks like photosynthesis,
even though we talked about
it, oxidative phosphorylation
first and then photosynthesis.
So you will, of course, looks
like oxidative phosphorylation,
but, of course,
remember, it's really
not that photosynthesis looks
like oxidative phosphorylation,
it's that oxidative
phosphorylation looks
like photosynthesis.
Now ultimately, the reason this
works is because photosystem II
and photosystem I can absorb
photons, which ultimately,
by the processes we discussed,
is what makes electron transfer
favorable from water to NADP+
to generate oxygen and NADPH.
Now, I want to take
you through just
to show you how this
works, because it turns out
it's also possible
to short circuit
this in a way that can
favor more delta psi,
delta pH production relative
to NADPH production,
which is important,
because you can imagine
that a photosynthetic
organism has to balance
its needs for NADPH and ATP--
both useful molecules,
but you want
to balance your needs
for both of them.
And it turns out that this
middle part, photosystem I,
works with cytochrome
bf in a way that
allows it to balance that.
So if I draw this out in
a little bit more detail--
so here's negative 1.6 volts
and here's positive 0.8 volts.
So that's, again, our
standard reduction potential.
So remember, water and oxygen
is going to sit down here.
You're going to have
in photosystem I
a special pair called P680.
That's the wavelength of light.
At the special pair in--
so this here would
be photosystem--
sorry, photosystem II.
That's a special pair within
photosystem II, absorbs photon.
That photon now becomes
an excited electron
that can be transferred away.
That ultimately makes
water a good electron donor
to resolve that
charge separation
at this special pair.
That electron is ultimately
transferred away, coming down
here to cytochrome bf.
So this moves from a higher
to a lower standard reduction
potential that's favorable.
So this should go here through
the pheophytin, QA, QB, et
cetera, through a
Q-like cycle to get
to cytochrome bf
and pump a proton.
That would then transfer
to plastocyanin.
That would then transfer,
ultimately, to photosystem I.
So there's photosystem I,
which also can absorb a photon,
excite that electron, which can
be rapidly transferred away.
But this time, rather than
water being the electron donor,
it's the electron transfer
from plastocyanin that resolves
the charged separation on the
special pair as you excite
and transfer the electrons
out, ultimately coming here
to ferredoxin, which is at
the right standard reduction
potential to reduce
NADP+ to NADPH.
And so this here also would
come through quinones.
A0, A1 is what those quinones
are called in photosystem
I. That's not important.
It's exactly the same thing
as what we described before.
And ultimately, this is
drawing out, basically,
what happens in the
chloroplasts, how photosystem
II and photosystem I fit in
with electron transfer in terms
of moving across standard
reduction potentials.
Now, what's cool is
that photosystem I,
rather than transferring
the electrons to make NADPH,
also can instead transfer
electrons as an alternative
back to cytochrome bf.
Well, if it comes back
into cytochrome bf,
you can see that
basically this now
creates a loop where you have
favorable electron transfer
here, excite, favorable
electron transfer, excite,
favorable electron transfer.
In essence, this here
will then pump a proton
by basically transferring
the electron back,
allowing you to run this
middle part between photosystem
I, cytochrome bf, and
plastocyanin, create delta psi,
delta pH at cytochrome bf.
And that allows you to make
ATP without generating NADPH,
or make a battery,
delta psi, delta pH,
do whatever work without
generating NADPH.
That's also shown here
on this slide, drawn out
in a way that may be
slightly neater than what
I drew out over there, but
effectively illustrates
the same thing.
And it's cool that
there's this flexibility
to run photosynthesis in a
way that you can net generate
NADPH, but you can also generate
just delta psi, delta pH,
allowing the plant to
meet its energetic needs,
because delta psi, delta pH
can keep ATP-ADP ratio high
when the lights are on.
And then that way, the
plant has all the energy
it needs to fight entropy
and be alive as a cell.
Whereas, it can also tune it,
then, to generate the NADPH
it needs to make reduced
carbon that it can then
store for later.
Now, to make the reduced carbon
that can be stored for later,
ultimately, now we have to
basically take CO2 and turn it
into carbohydrate,
turn it into glucose.
This CO2 into carbohydrate,
turning it into glucose,
that hexo-sugar that the
plant can then pack away with
alpha-1,4 linkages as starch to
burn later when the lights are
off, requires reduction.
That reduction electrons
have to come from somewhere.
Well, ultimately, they can
come from water via NADPH.
And those are the dark
reactions of photosynthesis.
And so let's discuss those next.
And so the dark
reactions, really,
are CO2 plus NADPH going
to carbohydrate plus NADP+.
These are reactions
that can happen either
in the dark or the light.
They're unique to
photosynthetic organisms.
That's who can net
carry out this reaction,
fixing carbon as glucose, as
reduced carbon and glucose.
These reactions,
these dark reactions,
are going to occur here in
the stroma of the chloroplast.
And why is that useful?
Because this is where the
NADPH and the ATP that's
going to be required for these
dark reactions to take place.
It should be clear to you,
NADPH is the electron donor,
but you also need
additional energy input
because this is effectively
reversing glucose oxidation.
That releases energy,
need energy input,
and so you're going
to see you also
need ATP to ADP conversion.
By happening in the
stroma, you have the place
where the NADPH and ATP is
being produced as products
of the light reaction.
So these dark reactions
of photosynthesis
were discovered in the
1950s by a gentleman
by the name of Melvin Calvin.
As a result, sometimes
the dark reactions
are referred to as
the Calvin cycle
to honor him as the discoverer.
And basically, the experiment
that Calvin did is he took
carbon dioxide that was labeled
with radioactive carbon--
so C14 carbon dioxide--
he basically fed it to
a photosynthetic algae
and found that the
first compound that
incorporated the radioactive
CO2 was a 3-carbon compound.
And that 3-carbon compound
was 3-phosphogylcerate.
Good old 3-PG from glycolysis.
And so he found that you could
get these reactions of CO2
going into 3-phosphoglycerate
is the first thing
to incorporate the
radioactive carbon.
That worked in the
light or the dark,
and that's where the term
dark reactions came from.
Now, it should be,
hopefully, clear to you
that if I can generate
3-phosphoglycerate,
you now know how
to make glucose.
Because now you can go
back and look at your notes
from the
gluconeogenesis lecture,
and if you had a source
of 3-phosphoglycerate,
you can just run it through the
reactions of gluconeogenesis,
and ultimately make glucose.
Turns out that the way
this happens in total
is the so-called Calvin cycle,
really happens in three phases.
So the first phase
is called fixation.
And so what is fixation?
That's basically
Calvin's experiment.
It's using CO2 to generate
3-phosphoglycerate.
The second phase is
referred to as reduction.
So what's reduction?
Well, that's basically
gluconeogenesis.
So it's using 3-phosphoglycerate
and turning it into glucose.
Gluconeogenesis,
we're reducing carbon.
This is the step, of course,
so you need electrons
from somewhere.
They're going to
come from NADPH.
We need NADPH for that.
You'll also need ATP.
And then the last step
is called regeneration.
And what you will see is that
the Calvin cycle is a cycle.
That is, you're going to have to
have an entry point and an exit
point.
And just like we talked
about for the TCA cycle,
if we feed two carbon acetyl
CoA units into the TCA cycle,
we have to have an acceptor,
oxaloacetate, in order
to run the cycle.
And if we pull anything
out of the cycle,
we need another way to add
carbon back to the cycle.
And so regeneration is really
anaplerosis for the cycle.
That is, you need to generate
the acceptor that you can
keep running this as a cycle.
As a general overview,
it works as follows.
And so it turns out that the
cycle works with this molecule
as, I guess, if we're going
to draw an analogy to the TCA
cycle, where oxaloacetate
was the initial acceptor,
this is the analogous
molecule to that.
This is a molecule,
it's a 5-carbon sugar.
So it's pentose
phosphorylated-- it's
a pentose and a
ketose phosphorylated
on the one and
the five position.
So this is ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate,
which I will abbreviate R15P.
So ribulose 1,5-bisphosphate
will pick up a CO2 molecule,
and it will make two
3-phosphoglycerate molecules.
So five carbons plus one
carbon equals six carbons.
Break them in half, two
3-phosphoglycerate molecules.
Once you have that
3-phosphoglycerate,
I can now use ATP
to phosphorylate
that 3-phosphoglycerate.
That'll give me
1,3-bisphosphoglycerate.
I can now run the photosynthetic
version of the GAPDH reaction,
which is exactly the
reaction that you
saw in glycolysis,
except now we're
going to use NADPH
rather than NADH,
as we described for glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis.
And so that's going to
give me glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
use triose-phosphate
isomerase to make
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And I can run aldolase
reaction to make fructose
1,6-bisphosphate, can release
a phosphate from fructose
1,6-bisphosphate.
Now I have fructose 6-phosphate.
I can isomerize
fructose 6-phosphate
to glucose 6-phosphate.
And of course, if I take the
phosphate off, that's glucose.
Or, more importantly,
what would the plant do?
It would then do
a mutase reaction
to make glucose 1-phosphate
and pack that away in starch,
much like we discussed for
putting glucose into glycogen.
And then get that
glucose back out
as glucose 1-phosphate,
glucose 6-phosphate,
and send it to glycolysis to
be oxidized to get energy.
This is great, but you can see
that this is not going to work
unless I can regenerate a source
of ribulose 1,5-bisphosphate.
Turns out, you can do that
from fructose 6-phosphate.
Obviously, ATP is going
to be required here, too,
because there's only
one phosphate here.
You need two phosphates for
the ribulose 1,5-bisphosphate.
So more ATP is needed.
And ultimately, that, in
a non-stoichiometric way,
is how the cycle works.
And so if we break this up
then into the different phases,
this phase up here
would be fixation,
this phase down
here is reduction,
and this phase over
here is regeneration.
And that's basically
the Calvin cycle.
Let's go through these
now one at a time.
Let's first talk about fixation.
Fixation is catalyzed by
an enzyme called RuBisCO,
which stands for
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
carboxylase-oxygenase.
So RuBisCO, if you
want a bit of trivia,
is the most abundant
enzyme on earth.
It's about 50% of the
protein in chloroplasts.
It's an incredibly
inefficient enzyme.
It has a turnover number
about three per second.
And that's why it's so abundant,
because it's a crappy enzyme.
And so therefore, it needs
to have a lot of it around
in order to work.
It evolved in a
pre-oxygen atmosphere,
and now, of course, there's lots
of oxygen in the atmosphere.
And CO2 and oxygen
will both compete
to react with the enzyme.
And it turns out that that's
a issue for photosynthesis,
and it's a big deal
for agriculture.
Now, the way RuBisCO
works is that there
is a lysine in the active
site of the enzyme.
And that lysine is covalently
bound to a CO2 molecule.
And that CO2 molecule
covalently bound to the lysine
is not involved in the reaction.
But basically, if you don't
have enough CO2 around
to carboxylate the
lysine, now you
can't carry out the reaction.
It's one way to
ensure that there's
enough CO2 that this will work.
But effectively, what that CO2
does is coordinates a magnesium
atom that ultimately coordinates
and positions the ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate within the
active site of the enzyme.
So here is ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate bound
into the active site of RuBisCO.
I'll show you quickly how
the RuBisCO reaction works.
And so if we take the enol--
or, the keto form of ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate and redraw it
in the active site as
the keto form so it's--
that will react with CO2.
You add water.
And then ultimately, what we
are left with from the top half
of the molecule, we get this
1,3-phosphoglycerate molecule,
and on the bottom part also get
a 3-phosphoglycerate molecule.
So two 3-phosphoglycerates
generated.
So ultimately, what's happening
is we're adding a CO2 basically
between the two and three carbon
of ribulose 1,5-bisphophate,
breaking the molecule in half
to get two 3-phosphoglycerate
molecules.
Just to quickly show you
what happens if at this step
if you instead replace this with
oxygen, so instead have oxygen
add there instead.
Well, now you end up
with this situation.
So now you have that instead.
Now, when water gets
added, you end up
generating from the bottom
half of the molecule,
of course, a 3-phosphoglycerate.
So that's not a problem.
But from the top
half of the molecule,
rather than generating a
3-phosphoglycerate, now
you have this
2-carbon unit, which
is called phosphoglycolate.
And it turns out that
phosphoglycolate is not
a good thing for
the plant to have.
You basically started
with 5-carbon ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate, and you end
up with 3-phosphoglycerate
and a 2-carbon phosphoglycolate.
No carbon is added
there, and now the plant
has to deal with the
phosphoglycolate.
So it has to regenerate the
ribulose 1,5-bisphophate.
So naturally, if
you're going to take--
rebuild that 5-carbon
molecule, that's
going to require energy input.
And you haven't fixed a CO2.
So in the end, what's required
is actually more ATP and NADPH
to solve the
phosphoglycolate problem
with no net gain for the plant.
And so as a result, oxygen
competing with carbon dioxide
is a big deal for plants.
By the way, dealing with
phosphoglycolate-- which,
of course, plants
have a way to do--
is a process called
photorespiration.
Photorespiration requires
all this ATP and NADPH,
so it requires all
this extra light energy
from the plant that's
really not being
used for any good purpose
for the plant itself.
Now, the process I described
is the standard photosynthesis
process, and it's what happens
in so-called C3 plants, called
C3 because a 3-carbon
intermediate is made.
It turns out that there
is also a class of plants
called C4 plants that basically
use a 4-carbon intermediate.
They do the same
thing 3 plants do,
but they basically have
a system that basically
uses some extra ATP
and NADPH in order
to generate a shuttle
to concentrate
CO2 to run the RuBisCO
reaction that I just showed.
And so that is shown
here on this slide.
And so this is what
happens in C4 plants.
And so effectively,
you fix a CO2 using--
basically, making oxaloacetate.
So that's the 4-carbon unit.
You run an NADPH-driven version
of the malate dehydrogenase
reaction to ultimately
generate malate.
And then turn that malate
back into pyruvate,
releasing CO2 back over here
into the different parts.
So use a PEPCK-like
reaction, send it
to the chloroplast,
where you then regenerate
CO2 for the RuBisCO enzyme.
And you send that
pyruvate back out as a way
to run a cycle that basically
concentrates the CO2.
So this requires extra
ATP, requires extra NADPH.
But in the end,
it saves the plant
the trouble of having to deal
with this phosphoglycolate.
Not surprisingly,
this has evolved
in places with high light.
So tropical plants are
more likely to be C4 plants
because they have more
light around, more ATP,
NADPH any way, that allows
them to compete with each other
and concentrate CO2 in
a way that allows them
to run the RuBisCO reaction.
All right, reduction,
the next phase up here.
There's actually
not a lot to say.
This is basically just
gluconeogenesis using NADPH.
And of course, you can use
it to generate glucose,
but plants would rather
generate glucose 1-phosphate
and store it as
starch or something
else, some storage sugar
for the plant itself.
Now, what should be clear
to you is that, well, we
started with a 5-carbon unit
and we added a 1-carbon unit.
And in the end, if we're going
to net generate a glucose,
we're going to have to run that
cycle six times, because we
need a 5-carbon unit
to come out the end,
as well as build a 6-carbon
unit just from CO2.
And so regeneration is really
how do we go from net six CO2
to one glucose molecule.
That is, how can we combine
that reduction step while also
regenerating ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate to keep
running this as a cycle?
And so, in essence, what we need
is we need to take six 5-carbon
units--
so that's a total of 30 carbons.
And we're going to
have 6x CO2 molecules.
There's another six carbons.
So that's a total
of 36 carbons in.
And then we're going
to have to allocate
those carbons to regenerate
six 5-carbon units.
So the 30 carbons, we need
it for the cycle, as well as
one glucose, the remaining
six carbons, that hexose.
How this happens is confusing.
I'm sorry, I didn't invent this.
Nature invented this.
But it's essentially
accomplished via series
of 2-carbon and 3-carbon swaps.
And why it's 2-carbon and
3-carbon swaps and not--
I don't know, why didn't
nature just come up
with something more
straightforward
is well grounded in
the chemistry of how
these reactions happen.
We'll describe the chemistry
of the swapping reactions
in great detail next time.
You'll see that the swaps occur
between aldosis and ketosis.
And so there's actually
good evolutionary reasons.
You'll see that those reactions
will be analogous to things
that we've seen before.
And effectively, nature,
rather than making it easy
for you to memorize
things, came up
with a way that
actually fit what
happens that enables carbon
rearrangement in a way that
will make this pathway work.
And so before I go into the
details of exactly how this
happens, I just want
to lay out for you
at a very, very high
level how those swaps can
work to accomplish this goal.
So basically, If we're going
to start with five carbons
and we're going to add CO2,
what's that going to generate?
Well, we're going to generate,
by the RuBisCO reaction,
3-carbon units.
So if I start with 6 of
these and 6 of these,
I can generate 12
3-carbon units.
I can take of those
12 3-carbon units
and obviously combine
them via the reduction
reactions, gluconeogenesis,
ways to generate 6-carbon units.
And that ultimately is going to
be the glucose that I get out.
So it turns out if I do
this reaction five times--
so that's 10 3-carbon units--
but if I take some
of-- so that means
I'm going to get in the
end five 6-carbon units.
Well, if I use
two of those units
and I do a swap with
the remaining two
of these 3-carbon
units-- that is,
I transfer two carbons
from here to there--
what am I going to get?
Well, if I-- that
means two carbons.
6 minus 2 is I get
a 4-carbon unit.
3 plus 2 is a 5-carbon unit.
That's good.
That's what I'm trying to get.
So I took two there, two here.
So that stoichiometry
adds up here.
I had 12 of these made.
5 plus 5 plus 2
equals 10, 5 of them
down here to these
guys, 2 of them
with this swap with
the 3-carbon units.
Now I end up getting two
of the six 5-carbon units
that I need to make.
Well, now I'm left here
with two 4-carbon units.
I steal here.
I took one away
here, two away there.
5 minus 2 minus 1 is
2 left, so I still
have two 2-carbon
units here to go.
So I can use my
remaining 2-carbon units
to react with those
4-carbon units.
If I now move three carbons from
here to there, 6 minus 3 is 3,
4 plus 3 is 7.
Now I generate a 7-carbon unit,
two of these, two of these.
Now, if I take two carbons
from my 7-carbon unit,
give it to the 3-carbon
unit, what do I have?
Well, now I have--
I've made two different
5-carbon units.
So 2 plus 2 plus 2 equals
6 5-carbon units back.
So it can work.
I will end today by drawing out
the details of how it works.
And then I will
redraw them next time,
and we'll go through in
great detail how it works.
So let's start here with our
ribulose 1,5-bisphosphate,
carry out the RuBisCO reaction.
I get two 3PG molecules.
I can run those 3PG molecules
using ATP and NADPH,
ultimately to generate
3-phosphoglycerate molecules.
I can isomerize--
I'm sorry, glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate molecules--
I can isomerize those
to also generate
dihydroxyacetone
phosphate molecules.
And, of course,
this is what I need
to generate FBP, and ultimately
generate fructose 6-phosphate.
And that fructose
6-phosphate, of course,
can be used to generate glucose.
And I'm not going to
draw the steps for it.
OK.
All stuff you know.
RuBisCO reaction and then
gluconeogenesis, ultimately,
to get glucose.
OK.
Now, here's where
it gets interesting.
So now let's use our
fructose 6-phosphate
and our glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
So I can generate
a 5-carbon sugar
called xylulose 5-phosphate.
That's a five-carbon sugar.
If I use an epimerase and
phosphorylate it with ATP,
now I can regenerate a
ribulose 1,5-bisphosphate.
I've also now will generate
this 4-carbon sugar
called erythrose 4-phosphate.
And I can take this
erythrose 4-phosphate,
swap three carbons,
which will give me
the 7-carbon sugar called
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate, as
well as a 3-carbon
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
Now I can swap
two carbons again,
and that gives me a ribose
5-phosphate and another--
so this is ribose 5-phosphate--
and another xylulose
5-phosphate.
So X5P, xylulose 5-phosphate.
I can now do exactly the
same thing I did before
with the xylulose
5-phosphate where
I do in an epimerase reaction
and phosphorylate it,
so epimerase from the
ribose 5-phosphate.
I can do and isomerase
reaction and phosphorylate it.
And in the end, I now
generate 5-carbon ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate.
So if I start with six ribulose
1,5-bisphosphates and six CO2
molecules, what
do I end up with?
Well, now I end up with 12
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates.
If I allocate two of them
here, five of them here,
and five of them
here, that allows
me to generate five fructose
6-phosphate molecules.
If I allocate two of them
there, pull one of them
out as glucose, and
the remaining two here,
I get two of these and two of
these, can carry this through.
Two of these and
two of those, is
two of these and two of those,
so I end up with
two here, two here.
That's two, four, six 5-carbon
units ending up as ribulose
1,5-bisphosphate.
And so I can feed six CO2's
in, get a glucose out,
and net regenerate six
ribulose 1,5-bisphosphates,
all at the cost
of six ATPs there,
another twelve ATPs here to do
the gluconeogenesis reactions,
and another six--
I'm sorry, twelve
NADPH's to generate
all of these 3-carbon units.
And in the end, pull out
one glucose molecule.
We'll start with this.
I know it's very confusing.
I will redraw that out.
I'll go through it again at
the start of the next lecture.
Thank you.